professor Ron who would come in and
determine a decedent's age their sex
their ethnicity and their stature me
okay and that title is forensic
anthropologists okay that is what I
specialized in I have my masters and my
bachelor's in Physical Anthropology age
sex race in stature we say race now we
say ethnicity God how to break it down
the simplest way to do it is we have
algorithms of we take measurements
that's the easiest way there's metric
and non-metric ways of determining age
sex race and stature I don't want to
bore you with all the details of this
but if there are a few people that you
want to be involved with for a few
reasons forensic anthropologists will
tell you exactly what you asked a
forensic archaeologist will help you dig
up the remains so that we can get to the
lab and the forensic anthropologist can
do what we do I'm a lab monkey I did my
work in in in UC Santa Cruz in the labs
oh that's where I got my my my feet wet
so to speak sometimes you will also hear
about forensic entomologists because we
can tell time of death which is another
story entirely in forensic entomologists
will get involved the three of them work
very very closely together a medical
examiner may have a forensic or will
probably have a forensic examiner I'm
forensic anthropologist on call maybe
even on their team bones love Kathy
Reichs she's the best forensic
anthropologists in the world right now
she wrote and created bones based off of
her books we don't walk in and have
we're lucky if we have a corner a little
loan you know touch screens and and an
entire staff and all that stuff I mean
maybe in Canada but not
here in the in the state it's not funded
that much and to tell you the truth we
don't find skeletonized remains that
often we do find them we do find them
but we it's more will find in various
stages of decomposition which we will
take into consideration as
anthropologists we are trained in
anatomy and and osteology which is bones
but from a screenwriting perspective
with this all this determining of the
age ethnicity happen in the coroner's
office where would this typical scenario
take place we can actually do this in
the in the very good question we can
actually do it anywhere is the is the
the broad answer we can do it in the
field we have field measurement tape
tapes we have osteo metric boards we
have for stature you know if you find a
whole decedent as compared to fragments
we have you know not yard shakes but you
know telescoping tell us telescoping
poles that can get some basic
information in the field so we can
because when you're trying to identify
somebody the first thing you need to
know is how tall are they what race are
they what ethnicity are they white are
they black are they asian are they mixed
we can tell some of these things by
looking at the bones we can tell some of
these things by examining remains now
one thing that I always want to make
clear in my classes and I like to make
clear here is human remains are not what
you see on TV human remains will start
decomposing within a few hours and
within a day or two unrecognizable as
human being sometimes other than the
fact that they're bipedal when there's a
you know a head on top you don't see
that on TV they say oh this person's
been dead six days and they look they
look like roses they smell the the smell
the
the sickeningly sweet smell of human
putrefaction forensic anthropology so
that's something for writers to take
into consideration is maybe a strong
reaction maybe somebody throws up maybe
they throw up three or four times my
professor and I always agreed throw up
and then get in there and do it if you
have to there is no myth in mythbuster
here there is no stuff to put under your
nose like in again so Silence of the
Lambs I did a decomposition study with a
deer once and I put vicks on my nose you
can smell everything because vics clears
your sinuses real good you think the
strong smell wood over do it now you you
smell you end up smelling more but
that's a tip that uh that a writer could
possibly use is you know trial and error
I walked into I was a realtor for a
while and walked into a house that was
on a caravan and all the agents became
sick because we were it was a probate
and so I experienced that and another
time like a coroner sticker was still on
the door and they had it listed things
like that what are some of the little
signs that if some was supposed to enter
a property and the body had been removed
but things like that the coroner sticker
would there still be tape would there be
you know biohazard on the door like what
are some of the little things biohazard
booties all over the place footprints
all over the place as bodies decomposed
they will have purged fluid which is I
mean if you get them within a you know a
day or two they still will they
decompose they they turn into liquid
basically that liquid can stain the
carpet it can it can stay it can it can
stay on the counter if it's not you know
hazmat hasn't come in and cleaned it yet
or even if they had particularly carpet
it'll go into the padding so you'd have
to replace all the carpet all the
carpeting particular if you want to sell
house my parents were real estate agents
I I feel for you what else can we tell
writers
yeah so there's metric and non-metric
variations i wish i could show them to
you right now but non-metric is the fun
ones we have a rule of thumb you ever
had sciatica run from the back here back
here from from your lower back and then
there's pain all the way down the back
of your leg not yet hopefully okay
that's called sciatica there's a sciatic
nerve in the human pelvis there is a
sciatic notch and we have something
called a rule of thumb if your thumb
just kind of fits in there it's a female
I'm sorry it's a male and if you can
move it around it's a female because the
females pelvic girdle spreads so the
notch becomes wider it's much more
effective when i play with fred back
here on the side but why call it that we
call out the rule of thumb so there's
there's something that a writer can play
with there but there are non-metric
variations that you can look up i highly
recommend starting at the university of
tennessee-knoxville website therefore
they're anthropology that's where the
body farm well one of the body farms but
there's there are many of them but
that's where the body farms was started
but start with their anthropology
department and they have links and you
can find all sorts of stuff
you